these polygraph examiner's during the
final four years of the war in Vietnam
in his new memoir of spies and lies
mr. Sullivan offers a perspective on the
war from his tours of duty in Vietnam
Cambodia and Laos this talk from the
National Archives in Washington DC is 40
minutes well about John Sullivan he was
born in New London Connecticut and
raised on the eastern end of Long Island
after graduating from Albany State
Teachers College he then taught history
at a high school in upstate New York he
entered the Army in 1962 and after a
year at the army language school at
Monterey California studying Russian he
was trained in military intelligence and
sent to Germany his tour in Germany was
spent with the 513th military
intelligence group and then he spent
nine months where was that and we were
learning German Oh abroad
I'll let him say when he gets up here
yes from 1967 until 1968 he attended
graduate school at Michigan State
University and while at MSU he applied
for a position at the Central
Intelligence Agency he was accepted and
from the June of 1968 until August of
1999 he was a polygraph examiner with
the Central Intelligence Agency during
his career he conducted more polygraph
examinations than any examiner in the
history of the Central Intelligence
Agency and a little over four of his 31
years at the CIA were spent in Vietnam
and that is the basis of his book so
please would you welcome John Sullivan
ladies and gentlemen thank you so very
much for coming down here and getting a
little rest bite from that terrible heat
outside I hope I can make you glad that
you came here today when I hope to
excuse me when I first got the idea of
writing a book it
okay when I the idea for writing a book
came to me quite frankly off the cuff
out of the out of nowhere I was in a
little bar unfortunately in a place
called bond me to it which is up in the
highlands of central Vietnam and I was
regaling to agency case officers with
tales of polygraph derring-do and there
are some interesting cases that I did
that you know make good conversation
when you're drinking a beer it's nice to
talk about one of the guys said John you
really ought to write a book I said I
think I will and I'll call it of spies
and lies as in Of Mice and Men I thought
that was kind of a cute title that was
the first thought I ever had about
writing a book the idea prior to that
time the idea never entered my mind and
it was just something that I said but
the idea was planted in my mind that
someday I would like to write a book now
when I joined the agency I knew writing
books isn't something that the agency
looked upon with favor and they
discourage people from doing that but
over the years I kept that thought in
the back of my mind and I said at some
point in time I will write a book and
I'll call it of spies and lies now I
retired in August of 1999 sometime in
1998 I actually started thinking about
well what do you want to write about you
know do you want to just a bunch of
anecdotes about polygraphed what do you
want to do I thought well that's what
I'm going to do I think I can write some
anecdotes that will be entertaining
maybe a little bit enlightening and I
think that that might sell a little bit
too I started writing the book and I got
in don't maybe the third chapter when I
started writing the chapter on Vietnam
and it occurred to me that one of the
things I'm going to have to do with my
book is give it to the agencies
kayson's Review Board for approval and I
thought while some of the stuff I'm
writing about they might not approve
whereas if I just focus on Vietnam most
of that material has been Declassified
by now it'll probably have a better
chance of getting through the
publication's Review Board also the
initial thought this is just going to be
too much of a book to many different
things I wanted to just focus on one
thing do that well and that might be a
first step in writing a second book
well what considerations that I have
when I decide I'm going to focus on
Vietnam well I'm going to write about is
my time in Vietnam the first thought I
had was what can I say about Vietnam
that hasn't been said already I don't
want to repeat stuff that other people
have written now four of my colleagues
who served with me in Vietnam had
written books of course I'm sure you're
all aware of Frank snaps decent interval
I bought that today it came out and I
read that and I felt it to be a very
informative book John Cassidy wrote a
book called stationed in the Delta which
is a fictionalized account of his time
down in mr4 which was the Delta and
there were some incidents there that
were very heroic very true one friend of
mine was very much involved in some of
these instance I I love that book I
couldn't write a book like that I don't
think I have the imagination for fiction
but that was a sample of what was being
written another book that was written
about Vietnam by a colleague was
slow-burn by Oren DeForest and frankly I
thought that was not a very accurate
picture of what was going on in Vietnam
and again it focused only on one area of
Vietnam a little Benoit mr3 in Vietnam
the final book that I read in
preparation if you will for this book
was Jim Parker's last man out now that
is a truly fine book about Vietnam but
there was more about Jim's military time
in Vietnam than there was about his time
with the CIA in Vietnam
when I saw that some point in time an
agency person should write a book about
what it was really like to serve with
the CIA in Vietnam not not that it was
necessarily very heroic very spooky
whatever very entertaining but if anyone
is going to learn anything about Vietnam
no one can adequately assess America's
role in Vietnam without understanding
the role of CIA in Vietnam after Tet of
1968 as the American military influence
in Vietnam drew down the agency
influence increased and for the last
five years in Vietnam American policy
American activity in Vietnam was
determined by decisions made by the CIA
I have seen no book - this date may be
mine hopefully but either than my book
I've seen no book that adequately
presents what the CIA did in Vietnam and
in a way that is true to true to life
and also interesting all right once I
decide I'm going to write on Vietnam and
I decide I've read these books what can
I say that is different what qualifies
me to write about Vietnam well in the
four years I was in Vietnam
I visited every province in Vietnam I
conducted more polygraph tests than any
examiner that was served there before or
while I was there I interacted with not
only more case officers but more people
in general than any other CIA person
serving in Vietnam all right I'm
qualified write about what you know I
don't think there is anyone that knows
more about how the CIA ran clandestine
operations in Vietnam than I I also had
an opportunity to spend a lot of time in
Cambodia I saw firsthand what was going
on over there I got to Laos on three
occasions I think I had a very very good
picture of what the CIA is doing during
the Vietnam War in that part of the
world now what other considerations that
I have
well one of my primary primary
considerations in writing the book was
in order to write an accurate book about
what the CIA did in Vietnam I'm gonna
have to trash some people I'm going to
have to say some bad things about people
who serve there with me now contrary to
the belief that polygraph examiner's are
sadists I'm really not and it bothered
me very much that I may have to write
some negative things about people with
whom I served some of them I liked very
very much in particular General Charles
timmy's I loved that man like an uncle I
mean I thought it was just as wonderful
a man decent human being as I've ever
met
but in my travels my interactions with
him it occurred to me that he's an
apologist for Arvin in the sense that
the South Vietnamese military could do
no wrong time and time again they would
do things they would desert they would
they had a terrible desertion rate and
frankly he'd cover these things up and
that information was not getting out and
I said well I'm going to have to write
some bad things about General Tamizh and
frankly that bothered me very much but
if in the name of accuracy accuracy I
felt it was necessary to do all so some
of the people I worked with were the
ugliest Americans that God ever created
they did more to hurt our cause in
Vietnam than to help it I would be
surprised at how much I actually took
out of the book personal anecdotes about
the concupiscence --is and the the greed
etcetera of some of the people with whom
I work but in the interest of not being
just a gossip book I felt I had to do
that so I took some of it out but that
was a very very difficult thing for me
to do write bad things about the people
that I work worked with another concern
I had was scuse me please
another concern I had is what is the
reaction by colleagues going to be in
the office of security in particular
which I was for 31 years I was assigned
to the office of security writing books
are talking about anything about agency
as kind of revoltin and how would I be
looked upon for having done that and I
finally realized that I don't want to
say but I really don't care I think I
have something to say about Vietnam that
has not been said before and if people
are going to understand what went on
over there I'm going to have to tell
people what they did and I felt that I
would be less than honest if I tried to
cover up the roles of some of my
colleagues over there it bothered me I
frankly don't whether I'll be getting
any hate mail or not I've had a couple
of people say well I don't like you very
much for having written that but prove
me wrong and maybe I'll change the next
with with the next addition but until
you can show me that something I wrote
was wrong I'm sticking with my story now
once I made the decision to write about
Vietnam and I I think it was I retired
on the 31st of August 1999 and on
September 1st 1999 I sat down at the
personal computer and began to write and
on three days I know I spent 14 days at
the PC but I just wrote and wrote and
wrote and it was really quite a horrible
mishmash by the time I got done but by
the time I had the first manuscript
ready to go I had someone look it over
and you know two people that I had
served with in Vietnam I asked them to
read the book tell me what you found
wrong with the book in terms of
factually wound my interpretation of the
facts may not be as accurate as some
other people's or as good as some
people's but find a factual error in the
book neither these people could find a
factual error in the book and I felt
very very pleased about that and the
point I want to make is this
I never took one note in in preparation
for this book not
not one note that I take I wrote
absolutely off the top of my head on
occasion I would certainly discuss with
my wife because she was there with me
whether this happened when I said it
happened etcetera and I had access to a
lot of people that served with me in
Vietnam and I would consult with them on
occasion but in terms of the factual
material they could not find one error
and that that pleased me great so I know
I have if you will a truthful book
another concern I had was if any of you
read the book you know there are an
awful lot of names in the book do I use
true names do I use aliases or what and
what I found very interesting I made the
decision to use aliases in the book and
if I do it throughout with few
exceptions some I think they are
commonly known with few exceptions I
could use a leus and felt that was the
way to go
I couldn't believe how many people asked
me to put them in in true name people
were calling me and saying Oh John I'd
really like you to put me in in true
name I I was retired I retired as an
open employee I'm sure there'll be no
problem but just in case I felt there
was I felt if I do everybody or everyone
in alias then I don't have to worry
about you know inadvertently putting
someone out there that doesn't want to
be out there so I did all the aliases
and I you know edited as best I could I
was sure it was factually correct and
then I submitted it to the agency's
public publications Review Board one of
the biggest surprises I've had in this
entire process has been how
accommodating the agencies publications
Review Board was dr. Steve cook he
spells it chaos eh but it's cook is the
head of the publication's Review Board I
can't believe one how helpful he was
just how accommodating they weren't now
the initial manuscript was a hundred and
six thousand words now as my wife would
probably tell you that's a days
conversation for me but out of one
hundred and six thousand words they
asked me to take out a total of nine
were
I know many people thought that if you
write anything bad about the agency
they're not going to let that in
absolutely not
and I know one of the people who
reviewed my book and gave me quite
frankly a very good review said that I
agencies publications review board
checked the book to make sure nothing
really incriminating got out well they
were very very in comic accommodating
and very very grateful so the
publication's Review Board what's next
well after I sent the manuscript and
they came back and they said okay it's
ready to go if you just make these
changes we'll have no problem with it so
I sent out query letters regarding you
know would you be interested in
publishing my book and I was getting a
while I sent out a total of nine query
letters I got seven rejections and then
I got two offers of a contract the
rejection letters are very very nice but
what my friends tell me people who have
written that's very unusual to have you
know to get an offer so quickly well one
of the office I got and I knew nothing
absolutely nothing about book a writer
publisher contracts but on the face but
I said this first contract this is not a
good contract I mean the things they
want to be delighted I don't think so it
was with believe me heart and mouth that
I turned this person down now one of the
query letters I had sent had been to the
Smithsonian Institute press the managing
editor in Moore Gatlin well mark wrote
back and he said John we don't do this
type of book but I have a friend at
University Press of Kansas who does this
sort of book and I think he might be
interested I wrote a letter to missed
again I died mr. briggs mike briggs and
he sent back and said yes we're very
interested just don't want a lot of
stuff about the technical aspects of
polygraph I'm the least technical person
that ever ran a polygraph test in the
world so that was no problem for me and
then I sent him the manuscript the first
thing they did was refer the
manuscript - - in quotes experts on
Vietnam and will have them read it and
if they like it then we'll take the next
step well I sent the manuscript in to
University Press of Kansas on the early
I know it was early October and I didn't
hear anything until the day before
Thanksgiving and I got a letter from mr.
Briggs saying here are the first
reviewers comments and although he had
some editorial comments and ways things
could be better he did not find one
factual error in the book and if I would
address the chronology you know make it
a little less confusing he would
recommend it for publication naturally I
was very elated and I thought well
that's okay the suggestions he's made
are are helpful and I'll do it and I
thought well the second review can't be
too bad and I was feeling very very good
I just thank God I didn't get it before
Christmas I got it that I got the second
reviewers comments the day after
Christmas and quite frankly he trashed
me I couldn't believe that someone could
find that many mistakes or alleged
mistakes in my book and it was a real
downer I thought oh my god what you know
what what is what is he doing to me well
quite frankly I had not treated him very
kindly in my book so I thought it was a
little bit of tit-for-tat but I wrote
Mike Briggs I said you know I'm really
disappointed in this I think it's a I
don't think a lot of his comments a
valid etc etc and so forth and Mike
broke back and said well would you be
willing to make the corrections or the
editing that he suggested and I said yes
and what I found out was once I began
following if you will his editorial
suggestions I became absolutely
possessed with writing the book and I
also found out there's a lot of what he
said that was very true I may not have
liked the way he delivered it but I
could not escape the fact that he picked
a lot of things in the book that were
weaknesses that needed adjusting and I
you know once I've been falling it it
was I became possessed and I know that
the book was bad
our product because of the criticisms
and the the trashing he did of my book I
finished that in about I think it was
actually early April of 2001 and I
thought well I'll send it in in May Mike
wrote back and said we are submitting
your book to our we're submitting the
book to our board for approval we think
it's going to go
congratulations etc in June I got the
contract and and I thought well gee how
long is going to take for the book to
get out well from the time you submit a
book for the time they get it out can go
anywhere up to two years but it's almost
a year to the day since I submitted it
that they actually put the book out for
publication now in looking at the book
and looking at the comments and reviews
that I've gotten so far I think one of
the fairest things that's been said
about the book is that my prose style is
not powerful it's work been like I'd
also like to state that of spies and
license is not a scholarly book I'm not
a scholar I don't write as a scholar of
books as I don't write as a scholar
Frank snaps decent interval was a
scholarly book it was written I think
for a different audience than mine I
want the average person who went to
Vietnam to be able sit down read the
book identify with me identify with the
situations that I was experiencing in
Vietnam not necessarily to sympathize
with me but to understand how
frustrating it was now as I said the
book is not a scholarly book but there
are lessons to be learned from being in
Vietnam there are lessons to be learned
from how we performed in Vietnam I
frankly think that some of those lessons
have been learned well
what lessons have been learned I know
that back in the late 70s and early 80s
I know there was a move afoot to go into
highear in the Congo to get involved in
that that particular venture that we
were involved in at that time
and I know the statement was made by
someone in high voice didn't we learn
anything from Vietnam let's not do this
same thing with the iran-contra there
were lessons that were learned over
there some are still being learned and I
think we have learned a little bit but
not enough but regardless of how much we
learned by our experience in Vietnam the
price wasn't worth it I thought you know
I writing this book as part Mia culpa
I'll never escape the feeling of guilt
for you know I I went to Vietnam not
necessarily a hawk when I was at
Michigan State I was a [ __ ]
five years in the military I went to
Michigan State where the radical
movement the anti-war movement was in
full bloom and you know I was saying to
myself who are these armpits with always
criticizing the values you know calling
our GIS baby killers those kids that we
sent to Vietnam we're every bit as
scared as that you know they were just
terrified fighting for survival and I
admired them greatly for what they did
and I hated these people for criticizing
these kids and yet as more and more
Vietnam War veterans begin participating
these part these protests as it were I'm
going to say maybe this that maybe it's
something we ought to listen to I
remember waking up in January of 1969
teen 68 and I remember listening to
Walter Cronkite as Ted of 68 started
Walter Cronkite saying hey I thought we
were winning the war well most people
did think we were winning it but we
weren't okay so I I really want you to
understand just how difficult our role
is and we did in many ways the best we
could unfortunately we didn't always
send our best and brightest to do the
best and that was a problem but that's
one thing I would like people to get out
of this that we played a role there it
was a very very difficult role it was
very very frustrating another thing that
I want you to understand from reading
the book was that losing the Vietnam War
was a cooperative effort everybody
played its role the military by not
reporting negative statistics certainly
played a role the the agency also got
into this mode of not really telling it
like it was I remember one incident in
particular and it's in the book
I attended a briefing this was in
February of 1975 two months before the
war came to an end and the person was
given the briefing was Frank's nap and
he was saying how everything was going
very well we see no real problems and
one of the people attending the briefing
stood up and said you know that may be
what's going on you know in the rest of
Vietnam it sure as hell is in what's
going on down here in the Delta we've
lost over half the provinces since the
1st of January and snaps answer was guys
I'm just quoting the party line so the
CI had a party going to him one of one
of the people attending the briefing
actually alluded to the fact he said you
know when Tom Polgara who was the chief
of station he met with Kissinger and
Nixon at San Clemente three months ago
when the word was out Vietnamization is
working and there's nothing going out of
Vietnam that says otherwise so we all in
the State Department certainly went
along with that so we all had a role to
play in the loss of the war in Vietnam
another thing I would like you to come
away with from reading of spies and
Liza's that wars are not supposed to be
fun and for too many Americans in
Vietnam I am myself included the war was
fun not long ago someone commenting on
the war in Vietnam said if the women had
been less pretty the war would last at
about six months and there unfortunately
there is a bit of truth in that
statement Vietnam for many people was an
escape from reality and we did not you
know we did not serve the Vietnamese
well by being there Tom polgár who was
the last chief of station in Saigon I
think he said it best we did not serve
these people well now mr. polgár and I
came to our PIFAN ease by different
routes
but the saddest part of my leaving
Vietnam is the fact that we did not
serve those people well now I know there
was a congressman from Connecticut who
speaking before Congress in January of
1975 commented that what we have in
Vietnam is a moral commitment not a
legal commitment therefore we don't have
to key that you know adhere to the Paris
Peace Accords well that means we're
morally bankrupt if our president
Secretary of State can't make a
commitment that subsequent presidents
will follow that that means our foreign
policies is weak and in particular to
Vietnam it was it was a betrayal of the
Vietnamese and I and I believe that so I
left with you know I will be forever
haunted by the fact that you know we
didn't do anything for those pay
anything positive for the Vietnamese
people and I don't think I'll ever
escape that sense of guilt and I also
last but not least what I want as a
polygraph examiner for 31 years no one
is more aware than I of the controversy
that surrounds polygraph I am NOT one of
these people that thinks it's the
fantasy that's going to cool a cure or
our security ills or I don't think well
let me put it this way it's not as good
as many of its proponents say it is and
it's not as bad as many of our
detractors say it is I think done
properly it can be very very useful and
I am an adherent of it I don't I I see
the potential for misuse but I think in
the current situation here I think it
can be very very useful there's a lot of
other things I'd like to say but in my
other experiences and talks like this
there have always been a lot of
questions so I would like to open the
floor to questions in please I will not
avoid questions I'll answer as directly
as I possibly can
please I grew up in Connecticut I'm
curious through the Congress
I see me see me afterwards and I'll tell
you that okay yes mr. Sullivan did did
the CIA successfully recruited assets in
the Vietcong apparatus that existed in
the South that was creating such a havoc
and a problem I don't believe that we
ever recruited a we I don't believe we
ever had a really successful penetration
of the VC anyone above the certainly the
village level now we in prior to 68 we
did have a couple that I'm very well
aware of that were dissatisfied with the
VC came to us they weren't smug they
would tell us whether there was going to
be a meeting and in one particular case
I know we weep at an air attack air
strike killed over 200 VC and
unfortunately one of the ones that was
killed was this guy that came to us said
he hated the VC and they did this and
that so he reported to us but in terms
of penetrations no now the number one
agent in Vietnam I call fireball in my
book he was according to the latest
information I have in this camp comes
from the North Vietnamese themselves we
did recruit an agent but he told us he
wasn't a VC absolutely denied instead he
was getting the information from someone
else I'm not exactly sure why he did
that I think he thought if he really
told us he was a VC we'd never believe
him because we'd had so many that that
just never were but it turned out this
guy actually was a VC but at the time of
the evacuation we offered to get him out
and he refused that gave me the idea
well maybe he wasn't really maybe he was
working actually working for the VC and
they were using him as a conduit to get
information that they wanted us to have
for whatever you know as convoluted as
that may seem as it turns out the guy
was the VC he was working for us the
military several other organizations
a real paper mill he gave us absolutely
great information but they arrested his
case officer the day that Vietnam fell
and he blew the whistle on this guy and
the agent fireball committed suicide
before we before he could be arrested
that is the only if you will penetration
that we had of the VC infrastructure
that I actually know was a VC but at the
time we did not think we did not know he
was actually a VC excuse me can you tell
me how accurate the polygraph is there
is okay this is what makes it art and
not science on again on a particular
situation Alfred recently I was called
by channel 7 and asked if I thought they
should test the people out at Fort
Detrick regarding this anthrax and I
said that's what the polygraph was made
for one issue did you take it or any way
involved in the removal of that anthrax
from the facility I said there are two
problems here one the person who took it
may not work there anymore you don't
know whether that person is still there
I absolutely believe if the person who
took it were to be polygraphed it would
show up on the polygraph the problem we
have with polygraph today and
particularly the intelligence we diluted
the more questions we ask the less
reliable it is now for example if one of
you right here now had your wallet
stolen just say you're sitting here also
and you realize your wallet was stolen
if it's a given that someone in this
room had to have taken it I feel quite
confident I could find out who took it I
I do but the more questions you asked
the less reliable it is there are so
many extraneous factors that impact on
the reliability of polygraph the
reaction between the examiner and the
subject can have a significant effect on
polygraph
I always tell junior examiner's or
people who came in after all after I did
that the person who tests you does not
have to like you but they cannot dislike
you and if they do you will never get an
admission
the most valid polygraph test is one in
which you see a reaction to a question
you advise the person that he's reacted
to the question and you get an
explanation for that reaction that can
be verified polygraph kane' less than
that it's what we call a swag that's a
scientific wild ass guess because you
really don't know that's the best I can
say I have done tests where I felt in
this particular case it was 90% accurate
but until you get that admission you
really don't know but I do think every
circumstances for every circumstance I
think the reliability changes that's as
good an answer as I can give you please
could you add something on the
linguistic dimension of conducting
polygraph exams in another language oh
absolutely
with a good interpreter I think it works
now there is nothing better than being
able to communicate one on one I've had
examples where you know the person I'm
testing will not speak to another for
example if the interpreters from his
country he said you know you'll be going
next year this guy is going to be here
forever and if the politics change he's
going to know that I worked with you
guys so that is a problem I found that
with a good interpreter it's not as
reliable as I would like but with a good
interpreter I think I think it is
effective but I have caught interpreters
I don't want to say sandbagging me but
changing my meanings of questions and
they do it they think well I'm just
helping I'm saving you from yourself all
right but I'd rather not use an
interpreter but if I can if I can do it
one on one I've conducted tests in
Spanish and German by myself and I've
used interpreters for a lot of different
languages
I'd prefer not to use interpreters but
if the interpreter is good and you have
to prepare the interpreter when you do a
test you don't just write out some
questions and say here these are the
questions what you do is you write out
the questions in English and you give
the interpret and say I want you to
write those out in your foreign language
then give me my list back
and now you're going to read the
questions to me to make sure that the
wording is correct I don't let them look
at my typewritten questions you read
them back to me they'll make sure that
the questions are worded as I want it's
a it's a handicap but one that can be
overcome if that answers your question
sir please going once
all right let me get over here I don't
fully understand your reasoning mr.
Solomon for using aliases in the book
well many of our many of our people
agency people retired undercover they
have never acknowledged and cannot
acknowledge that they were agency so if
you've retired undercover I can't put
your true name in the book I mean that
might there's some people in particular
that are in jobs right now some teaching
colleges that don't want it known that
they work for the CIA
so that that's the rationale for that
sir methods and sources know that I
absolutely not know Sam that is the fact
is that many of our people are
undercover they're not openly known as
they didn't see employees and I'm
certainly not going to expose them if
they don't want me to a you know if
they've retired undercover I am
perfectly willing to let them stay that
way sir
in these polygraph tests that you
administered of what or conducted what
who were the people for the most part
that you were giving these tests to I
mean were they the Vietnamese were they
90 percent of them yes yes they were
Vietnamese men they were Adan that our
people had supposedly recruited now for
example most of the agents that we had
in Vietnam were recruited by members of
the South Vietnamese Special Branch I
mean our people couldn't go out into the
countryside and meet one-on-one with
people I mean there's no way that that
could be done they stuck out as I said
in my book like Wilt Chamberlain a room
full of roomful of midgets
so the Special Branch would come to us
and say I have a
I that's a security Kadri in the VC well
we have to polygraph them my first in my
first six months in Vietnam I found out
at least five that had that were not VC
there were complete fabricators etc but
ninety percent of people I trusted
excuse me I tested North Vietnamese
prisoners of war
I tested local Vietnamese who were
employed by us as interpreters as
barbers whatever I tested other foreign
nationals that came to us for example we
had a foreigner come to us one day in
Saigon and claimed that he was aware of
a mission to blow up the embassy they
were going to attack the French Embassy
was which was right next to us go
through the french embassy come into our
embassy and blow it up while he turned
out to be a fabricator but the point is
most of the people i tested were
vietnamese agents support agents that
sort men
please the last question here
I'd like to take off on your comment
about where the war should be fun and
how this relates to how guys are built
and what makes guys run and fight I know
a guy who actually I think still works
the National Archives of an Irish name
who's very Irish heritage who said the
year in Vietnam and he said he's all for
peace but he knows himself well enough
to know that what he had Tiny's me most
felt alive was when he was in Vietnam so
he'd feel it'd be hypocritical to come
out as peace Nick and I was so wondering
how much you experience correlates with
religious and ethnic heritage the
religious training and I wish whatever
just like the the FBI is a great place
for Irish points to and particularly
this place in McCarthy is and what was
really behind McCarthyism and one thing
it said is a war between the ethnic
Catholics and the wasp Protestants like
Dina jusen from whose father was
Connecticut Bishop of it's critical and
how do you feel that this tract and this
is a no-no subject to talk about
even with mrs. Howe the question I'm
sorry it's a little bit complex but I
would say this that there were good
people in Vietnam and there were a lot
of young kids a lot of people who had
never been exposed that type of an
environment before I am very very
fortunate that I had my wife with me in
Vietnam that made all the difference in
the world but I would suggest that you
know good guys are good guys boys will
be boys and Vietnam was a it was a
sexual cornucopia for people who'd never
been exposed to that environment before
and the VD rate was horrible over there
among our people but I can't you know
beyond that I I really don't know what
to say I don't think the way guys are
built had very much to do with a
situation that I saw in Vietnam one of
my colleagues in the agency I was having
dinner in his house one night and
he was asking me about the war and I
made the off off the wall not off the
wall come and I just made on the side I
said the only thing we did in Vietnam
was make it a bigger whorehouse and
that's not a very nice thing to say but
my that's what I saw when I was there I
mean what we did to the Vietnamese
society
get me Vietnamese society I wasn't ready
for 500,000 American GIs they weren't
ready for the consumer economy they
weren't ready their family the
Vietnamese have a very very strong
family structure and all of a sudden you
have their sons who are shoeshine boys
and their daughters who are bar girls
making more money than the father that
ruined or really disrupted the family
structure in Vietnam a night I felt
guilty about that I don't think I was an
active participant in that but I felt
guilty about at night but the idea that
because guys are made a certain way I I
can't I can't really address that man
yes please what I'm trying to do is put
together a book about if my title right
now is in search of truth as the CIA and
polygraph as a CIA lie-detector
polygraph examiner I guess I am someone
who is in or has been in constant search
of truth I think there's a lot to say
about the role of polygraph in the CIA I
think it's going to be a much more
broader concept book than this one is it
will address the whole world aspect of
how it's worked around the world that's
where I am right now I'm working on it I
think I'm going to have a little more
difficulty getting this one through the
publication's Review Board than the last
one but I hope it'll entertain as well
as enlighten just as I hope my book of
spies and lies will do I hope you're
entertained by it I hope you're
enlightened by it and that's about all I
can say but thank you all so very much
john sullivan was a recruiter team
leader and polygraph examiner for the
CIA from 1968 to 1999 his memoir of
spies and lies is part of the modern war
study series at the University Press of
Kansas visit Kansas press K Ueda